una persecución que ya terminó la
policía del Condado de Los Ángeles en
Estados Unidos encontró sin vida el
conductor de una furgoneta sospechoso de
haber matado a diez personas y por lo
menos herido a otras 10 durante la
celebración del año nuevo chino en
Monterrey Park en la madrugada del
domingo se trata de Hook de 72 años
quien se quitó la vida la búsqueda había
comenzado unas horas antes a unos 40
kilómetros del lugar de los hechos luego
de que una camioneta blanca se vio
involucrada en un enfrentamiento con la
policía de momento no se sabe cuál fue
el móvil del atacante pero la policía
encontró pruebas en el vehículo durante
la búsqueda varias piezas de evidencia
fueron encontradas dentro de la
camioneta
vinculando al sospechoso con ambas
locaciones Monterrey Park y Álamo
adicionalmente un arma fue descubierta
dentro de la camioneta
no se ha descartado que se trate de un
acto racista en una ciudad de 61.000
habitantes cuya mayoría es asiática o
asiático americana
es muy sorprendente chocante escuchar
que algo así sucedió no solo en una
ciudad pequeña sino en mi ciudad nunca
piensas que le pasaría a tu pueblo o
algo así
la violencia Armada no es frecuente en
Monterrey Park en un país donde más de
44 mil personas murieron por heridas de
bala en 2022
[Música]